yeah hello and welcome it with this
video a bit of a sound intro there I
didn't got the microphone right at the
beginning so let's play some games
aiming for roughly a 30 minute video
here and let's see what happens I
actually did record a video yesterday
but I had to had to toss it that was
really awful because I have to check
this again and now this screen Estate is
right I did totally screw up the the
screen so the board was impossible to
see I mean was kind of kind of odd
looking I still have that recording
maybe somewhere it was just like oh my
god yeah I played like 30 to 40 minutes
and into the video and then I saw oh my
god there was often not yeah because you
just couldn't use it um okay so let's
see we have a green felt here and kettle
green felt with c6 solid variation we
saw this line also in the candidates you
know who was white one how
in one house against Alexey anko and it
in a draw one difference there was that
one how played in early night B to D to
which I did not do um one reason form
[Music]
I'm not playing this so early as that
night see three turns out to be usually
a good reply to any a5 setup so
I'm in the rather move all the
subtleties
okay
what you do here not so sure actually I
can go before in this position
I wouldn't mind to take on d5 if he
takes with the pawn I would have Queen
to b5 this usually good form a little
bit of a little bit of pressure but if I
take he can also take with the Queen
which is
irritating me a little bit
there's also before I okay let's go
before I'm a little bit too slow here
actually I shouldn't have spent a minute
a type of position that had definitely
no
[Music]
interesting yeah I more or less have to
take
who looks really passive okay now is b5
a good move here
he has Bishop d3 huh
that's a bit of a bit of a letdown okay
Roxy one
you
yeah no I'm going to play b5
I want to prevent
I see six now it's them anyway in this
position I could go Bishop age three now
this is an interesting moment actually
let's do this the rare opportunity Jim
if I go 92 is still s Bishop d3
interestingly enough I have nice g5 in
this position this is very interesting
let's do this Bishop d3 I can take on e6
with the knight bit of an unexpected
tactic here
you
nina takes Bishop takes check and the
bishop is winning this night back i
guess he probably wants to move the
bishop now but this is not really great
I mean Bishop b5 I have night f4 okay
didn't expect this more so my night is
not actually attacked anymore that means
I can simply play
[Music]
keep the material
sure that this was best but
it must be good enough for a pretty
substantial advantage
night will come to a form and detect the
spawn
[Music]
so weights about it moment them
Bishop a3 is what he wants to do I guess
it's a tough call if you would want to
take the bishop
we should a3 is extremely annoying so
I'm going to take it this is really not
easy I don't I mean I liked my night
damn absolutely
Bishop III was really a problem
the night here ma'am I might have a good
spot on C for this is what is annoying
him still if it goes to C for F 3 E 4
becomes more of a possibility
yeah that's true Oh anyway I'm
really optimistic that
[Music]
I'm converting this and it's good that
the position has become a little bit
easier to handle given
situation
okay that I'm taking wait you can take
with the pawn
okay
2295
gypsy 3 it's um
good for white
I'm ready to play you find I don't see
him stopping that
you
kingi five maybe
but what
do
No
you
so difficult to ever play
lately for here
G for if you take city for
then I'm he can take on deform silly it
was very silly I did not
did not
[Music]
not see that
maybe this first
then you form
okay
you
and those two points can be can be a
problem
I'm absolutely seeing the point
you
you
unbelievable
you
ten seconds and he is going to get rubgy
one and it's a self-wringing
unbelievable game again
yeah I mean this is like why why is this
I mean it came
you have to be precise now and I only
had 10 seconds to do it
bishop c 7g three years winning hero
came
I mean this might still win but it's
going to know it's lost already
yeah they have porn it's extremely
dangerous
I mean I am I simply should prepare this
better I didn't I didn't see that after
you form this this is hanging it was my
idea and if I just play a smallish move
I'm winning this I think fairly easily
and I'm something like this King XIII
and she's just winning for what okay so
a new game
may my conversion of winning positions
is really poor if I would convert some
more I mean I would easily be rated 2700
he on that side
easily we stalk him is that actually
John none could be he was Auden the ICC
for a very long time with that name but
it's no GM in there the rating would fit
you
cane
a three that's a little bit uncommon
nation of moves let's say usually if
white goes for before based setup they
play the night to d2 and not to c3 but
this is interesting because b5 also
becomes an option
or white try to
and tried to fight for the d5 square and
interesting
yeah I wonder I need some counterplay
him
it was clear it was clear that you will
play that [ __ ]
again this is not something to
like timidly I'm just going to go for
this full fledged attack
so if I take him
which I obviously wanted to do he's got
Knight g5 and Queen b3 check
guy that means that my whole concept
doesn't work but anyway we have to have
to handle this in some way
you
this is still not not totally clear
disposition
King age to a half Queen d7 and King g2
I don't know kingi - I don't know
an ITF forum is probably helping him
now let me just play this
and take the pawn
he cannot easily take on v6 as an idea
for hit hits and my ideas simply Bishop
d7 who gave aid
yeah and it's maybe not entirely clear
this this situation here
definitely not enough in a blitz game so
he wants to lay Queen d6
maybe
you
yeah not much to
it
you
26 not really danger
right I just go Queen f7
now this is not bad I don't think it's
so bad
okay now this is a problem book f8 this
rook a7 that's really not
so nice
into a 526 I'm giving away b6
you
yes Luke h3 now
how do I ever ever ever
those pawns win ce6 maybe and an idea or
for a five
I don't have to make a decision
it's not the most natural move ever
my original idea was a six simply giving
up that porn on b6
Oh ready Chung
you
yeah a 5 he always has 26 that's not
really helping me
okay
Dewayne interesting
you
is going choice
good of seven here came
I'm playing as well
at the end of term we'll come to some
kind of time scramble Bishop f8 is just
so terrible
let's correct this sign
you
come on
I wanted to do this anyway that was my
first instinct to simply ditch their
pawn and and go for go for Queen f7 who
gave aid
yeah it's not really
doing that much
you
and 96 what a session I'm already doing
stupid stuff
okay
and what he did wasn't the best but it's
probably good enough
unfortunately
his king is totally safe
and not anymore
it also applies
my king of course
you
this one book age one mate
you
[Music]
what
you
yeah very
lucky okay yeah I don't know there was
many things going on in this game um
probably this isn't sufficient yeah it's
probably not entirely sufficient
okay okay the engine says this is kind
of okay but it's so difficult to play
what like him
Jim
so I'm just clearly better here okay in
five more or less winds which is not
entirely obvious
I'm just running you know him
it was very difficult I didn't quite
didn't quite understand
ship CH is again good for me okay
Jim
yeah I wonder ever actually had some
chances here after after this situation
because like in just in the Scramble
which is very random of course I wasn't
really sure what was going on so it
seems that why this is just winning him
86 Sam
[Music]
Jim yeah this is Nita I cannot take
cause our checkmate okay so another game
maybe I can can win one of those good
positions that would be nice actually
like it's a bit frustrating if you like
winning every game at some point and you
have a zero points old painless okay
so we're getting
getting some kind of Kings Indian
position
with an early a pawn push
really metal
I just wondered if if there's a move
order thing here but I should play first
but this is fine
[Music]
I could have played before actually in
this particular position
maybe
I don't mind 85 sorry a three
you
so I'd like to go in for awesome
it's preparing that
they play something else you might go on
itv4 and stop the c4
push for quite a while
and so let's go back
you
okay Jim and we do something
rustic already I don't know I mean
before looks good
it's a bit hard to believe that black
should be fine against all those pawns
you
aim
I cannot so go night G one in this
position
taking should be okay
you
okay now so take on c5
it should be fine
you
hmm yeah I just give up I will never
predict a move that this guy plays it's
all so weird and and and honestly bad
but
it's um
sometimes you just have to stop thinking
about what they could do if you if you
recognize that they will place some kind
of you know erratic move it just is a
waste of time to think about their
intentions
this is one of those cases
strange like night eggs and you bring
the night should be true I mean what
kind of play is that
came
you
yeah
[Music]
not even bad
at least I don't see how to
to kill it off
you
not exactly what I wanted to do
you
strangely enough that night on b2 was so
annoying that
was difficult to ignore it is probably
going to take be five or some something
like that
no this one is equally crazy
you
you
we're going to be too as a bit of a
problem
sometimes he's even threatening to take
on g3 and give up an exchange or
something like that
you
yeah Blake is very okay
you
I couldn't take because of Quincy one
check
you
I wants to go to age five
the Queen
you
it's not going to age five at least
you
going to be difficult Roxy eight sir is
the issue
just e5 right
nice running out of
shrieks now
that was a truly weird game all those I
mean it's like I don't
it's just super erratic he pushed
everything this to a3 and like g5 and g4
I was like very very strange stuff that
that's kind of minutes it's just so far
away from my type of chess that it
irritated me a bit
so night D takes I mean after D takes
this is kind of
yeah maybe 90 eggs it's actually not bad
it's just like it's just so odd
that you give white this huge Center and
don't take it and so on but the way it
turned out
yeah this is not it's not that terrible
night b1 seems to be good but I just
couldn't stand this night any longer and
he probably had something good here I
mean this looks like a really shaky
position f5 is another move and it kind
of shocks me for it's so ok it's still
ok
I mean at least I it seems like I didn't
allow some kind of some kind of killer
blow okay so one more game and then I
have to stop got something to do maxime
[ __ ] cough at least I'm on 2500 again
let's do something something solid for a
change
for pasta them
brewing so much coffee I should at least
drink it faster so I don't have to waste
anything
oh this is good
give me the old sugar anywhere can make
a million moves and in no time
it's exactly right for early morning
chefs
you
yeah if you know my channel or know my
games
he would have seemed his line I've
played it a million times
I also played a lot in over the board
chess with a really excellent results
I won games and only lost one against a
strong Grandmaster
they drew lots of gm's and I am Swiss
with black
very very very
during a game
okay
a couple of options here I can he has
not ever played a four that is
interesting
so he's going to his preparing and for
indisposition
mmm it's a tough one
just do this be ready to I know that was
the point
you
see what happens maybe I'm somewhat
mmm f5
yeah come on I'm not so badly positioned
to play this I think
unless he can hit me with with something
like age five that could be a real pain
if that would work
interesting I can just take you for
right
I mean I'm on this quite quite a bit
here with Queen Bishop and so on I'm
taking it
now do we take on g5 first or how do we
handle this
yeah doesn't look
man right g5 no is just totally lost
he cannot take on h7 that it just
wouldn't work
rook takes rook h1 check night h5 is
working and here I'm threatening Bishop
g5 and also night h5 is winning a threat
what the heck
what
g5
sorry I don't get it
what is the idea what's a trick rook g6
no doesn't work
I'm stupid I don't get it
my - 5 also worked but I just don't get
this at all
okay
you
still not stop
threat
anyway and I did five works I think
Bishop d2 1 through h7 checkmate
you
you three is just collapsing
everything is hanging Queen g3 Bishop d2
Bishop h6
you
this is easiest
and in fact Bishop b2 was still made on
h7 so not even easiest probably just
best
yeah be sure
winning this night
you
yeah I'm always happy to have this
opening in my repertoire because it's
not really a fantastic line but I've
played it oh my god so often that I can
play somewhat reasonable moves in
QuickTime and this is some helping if
you don't feel so fresh I love to play
the sveshnikov and I don't think
actually this is just it's a an opening
that is totally against my playing style
it's just like I need to be fresher
somehow for this and these kind of
positions I feel I can play in with my
eyes closed
oh yeah five was already strong yeah
that's kind of it's kind of well once
you see it know he hasn't really
prepared this so well and this is
hanging
this also probably wasn't so terrible
but he has better defensive options here
yeah yeah Bishop Bishop g5
should use straightaway
and it it basically does
you know there was no no trickery that I
missed ok guys hope you enjoyed the
video I'll be back tomorrow with the new
one thanks for watching
you